[Music]
I'm leeway and I work at a startup
downtown cop paedon and today I'm going
to talk to you about how we designed our
scalable financial data story so
starting with a brief agenda I'm gonna
tell you a little bit about me before
moving on to the data engineering
challenge for a building a financial
data story and then after that I will
dive into the mistakes we made before
getting to the meat of the talk our
solution and lastly I'll talk to you a
little bit about where we landed so
about me embarrassing photo I graduated
from Columbia two degrees so it's great
to be back and I started my career of in
business intelligence working mostly on
getting metrics to surface to our
business partners and kind of gradually
transition to data and power for
engineering right now I'm team lead for
a platform team at button and I work
with a group of super talented engineers
building out some of our court platform
services and lastly fun fact
I love Super Smash Brothers I played
those a lot in my spare time
probably it's out okay more time to that
than I should so on to the data
engineering challenge as data engineers
I don't know if you have experienced
this but you are more likely than not to
be asked to provide a source of truth
for downstream customers and your users
tells you that your data need to be
accurate timely and easy to use and this
is kind of tough when your users are
very varied and they use your data in
different ways
this is particularly a challenge I would
argue for financial data at any company
almost everyone is dependent on
financial data in one way or another but
they all kind of have to film ways to
access it and use it I have a diagram
here of in the middle you have financial
data and outside you have all the users
who use that data so I'm gonna start
with the most obvious one let me see at
this point it works so you have the
finance team obviously finance team uses
financial data to fill your users your
clients and they also used us to report
back for the health of the company to
your board and then on the right you
have the sales team whose performance is
actually tied to how much revenue they
bring in so they have a vested interest
in accurate measurement of financial
performance and then with marketing a
lot of marketing a lot of marketers uses
dollar metrics to track the success of
their marketing campaigns and I'm going
to shift focus to a different use case
which is for customer support customer
support once you see once you observe
the data lineage over your financial
data they tend to look at one or two
orders and figure out what happens to
the order
why was the order commissioned this way
like why is the order deleted and lastly
you have engineers and other services
who talk to your financial data steward
through your api's oh sorry I forgot
about data analytics data analytics is a
very special usage pattern in and of
itself your data scientists like to
slice and dice your data by arbitrary
columns and you can predict ahead of
time how they will what type of insights
they need to gather from your data so
taking all of the aggregate groups in
your company I've collected a list of
five access patterns they include
aggregate performance we provide user
CSV exports with raw financial
transactions we provide users list
endpoints to programmatically fetch
those transactions
you have API endpoints for talking to
other services and lastly we propose
data downstream for analytics so quick
overview of a very simplified version of
what the system looks like in the
beginning you ingest orders your process
orders you add new fields you figure out
how much the Commission is and then all
of the orders go into your financial
data store and that is the source of
truth for publishing to downstream users
so for reporting and analytics we
provide a pub sub that the analytics
team can listen in to and they take the
data and port it to analytics data
warehouse for us we use rush shift and
I'm for reporting we have a separate
service that also listen into the stream
and aggregate the data into purely
computer metrics so for the service
itself it provides two additional access
points one being kind of like credit
api's for other services and the other
being the ability to bulk export data
from the service so after taking stock
of all the ways our users want to access
the data we came to the following
conclusion the real challenge with
working with financial data is that you
kind of have a mix of OLTP and all API
access patterns as everyone is like I as
everyone familiar with the terms yeah ok
cool then I'll skip the explanation so
the OTP use case is fairly obvious we
are literally dealing with transactions
and every single write to the database
translates to dollar exchanging hands so
this means that the service can have no
downtime high availability and we need
to support low latency writes all
characteristics of LTP and lastly
accuracy is crucial and having acid
properties from the datastore is the
nice thing to have on the oil AP side
most of the use cases I
discussed right before I actually allow
AP use cases because the users need to
access a large number of Records they
look at say the last month over the last
years of data and figure out the total
aggregations based on those records so
for the oil AP users we need to allow
easy aggregation easy performant
aggregation the ability to fetch a huge
number of historical records and very
very fast
and lastly offered the analytics users
the ability to slice and dice over any
number of any set of fields so next up
the first time we tackled this problem
we made a few mistakes some a bit of
historical context here I think when you
work at a start-up the first time you
build out your financial data store as
when you first started making sizable
amount of money money that's enough to
warrant investing engineering resources
to building out this framework so that
is what we did and we thought at the
time that we only needed to support OLTP
use cases and that was as you can tell
from a previous slide Ronn assumption
the biggest mistake that we made in our
first iteration was that we were over
writing transactions with the latest
date this means in this example here
that users are not able to access the
history of events that happened over
time they're only able to see what the
status today so we have our customer
support Chris who sees that order total
was two hundred dollars two days earlier
and a couple days later he sees that
it's two thousand dollars and it's
completely unclear for him what happened
in that process it could be a system
book it could be that the user modified
to order but he because he doesn't have
that history he cannot say for sure this
was also as you can imagine problematic
for the finance team imagine your
finance team download your CSV on
January 1st and they compile 500 all of
these numbers are made up so take it one
gram so they compile for half a billion
dollars in revenue and then a couple
days later they read download the file
and they see it went down to 350 million
so this is problematic for them because
they can't use the data until it
stabilizes and they also don't have a
view into what caused the change and a
separate user pain point that the race
to us outside of immutability is that
the experts were taking them very very
long to download sometimes it takes
upwards of two hours three hours to
download the set of data that they're
searching for so we kind of saw a lot of
discontent expressed by users of
financial data across the company and we
were because of this content we were
given a second chance to rebuild our
system for it better and these are the
five data choices that we made so for
the data redesign we thought about how
could we redesign the data to better
serve our users the first principle is
kind of obvious we move from immutable
data to
immutable data which means that records
are only inserted never updated in place
so why immutable the previous lights
showed that this was the biggest pain
point faced by users users want ability
to track changes over time and the last
one is kind of obvious like financial
data should never be mutable it's
something that accountants have been
using for centuries in financial book
keeping they never cross out an entry
and just write whatever they want they
always only add to their bookkeeping so
what do you mean really with
immutability comes a couple benefits you
get the ability to audit what happens
and the other benefit is you can
reproduce the latest state of an order
at any point in time not just the latest
date and the last benefit as you can by
having this data lineage you're able to
correct for anything that you did wrong
in the next accounting period by simply
inserting a correction record so this is
how we restructure data again simplified
suppose a user books a hotel and they
extend into ten nights previously there
was the only one record with the latest
total 2000 but now instead they see two
separate events one for the creation
event and second for the adjustment
event and the totals reflect the change
and the order total that results from
the event and lastly you have a brief
message explaining what happened so
having this data explains what the
customer support departments observed
earlier they can now say with certainty
that having to order total be updated
from two hundred to two thousand was not
a fluke but actually an user event
moving on to the second design choice
that we did was to use Delta for easy
aggregation Delta means that instead of
showing the latest amount
showed a change in amount that results
from the event so as you saw in a
previous example every event mapped to
an amount that's the change and not the
latest and the benefit of using Delta is
you can easily aggregate them through a
simple linear function to get the total
and this is important for a lot of use
cases for our data tape because we
reformatted the data they no longer need
to both on the right side is the
previous rush of query for fetching
total Commission and total order and on
the left side is the new query after we
made the data update so you can see that
before users need to figure out through
a kind of like a window rational
function what the latest event is for
every single order as partition by order
ID and sorted by event time and then
they take the top records from that and
then they can get the total order amount
with the new design by moving from
latest to using deltas the user can just
run a simple some aggregation over all
the records this also extends to our
marketing and Finance folks a lot of
people in your organization are not
engineers and they don't have the tech
savvy to write an excel vba script that
can just figure out what the latest
amount is and PO it out with Delta's
they can simply just add a some excel
function and it will aggregate it as
they expected so diving a little bit
more into the choice of Delta versus
latest date and the impact on the data
pipeline architecture itself with Delta
as mentioned you get easy aggregation
you also kind of have a source of truth
for computing that Delta a lot of your
downstream users will probably need to
compute Delta themselves if you don't
compute at upstream so here you have a
single service responsible for that
calculation deltas are also kind of
atomic in a sense that every event
as a self-contained description of the
change this means that if you get events
out of order you can apply them
independently of each other
and your end state will be eventually
consistent which is really nice which is
really nice to have if your pipeline
cannot guarantee ordering so with latest
date there is one benefit you get
greater tolerance for missing events
because later events will override the
previous date so if you were to miss one
event and you can be guaranteed you'll
receive a later event the missing event
is not a big deal we use art system uses
sqs for passing messages between
services and Amazon only recently wrote
out Scifo which which gave you up
ordering so far as the ability to have
changes that can be applied
independently of each other without
ordering and still have eventual
consistency was a powerful principle to
have was a powerful attribute to have so
moving on to the third data design
choice we decided that our previous
scheme and had a to normalize design and
now is the biggest contributing factor
to why the CSVs were taking so long to
run so with the new design we went with
fewer tables but with a lot of
dimensions so Y Z normalized going back
to the previous challenge of supporting
both o AP and all TP use cases
de-normalized is usually the schema for
the all ap use case and you can see that
we actually had more ap use cases then
we have all TP use cases so this is kind
of a summary of what we said previously
Li P includes marketing finance data and
partners whereas the old TP use cases
include processing transactions and
supporting customers support so we kind
of went with a hybrid approach here by
picking a traditional OLTP like
relational database we picked Postgres
but we store the data
Farida more normalized format and this
is not very much the end state but it
gave us the permit performance that the
performance gains that we wanted on the
left you can kind of see the previous
financial data story schema
there are almost 20 tables all with
foreign keys pointing to each other and
a single read-through for single
transaction records meant a lot of
querying and that meant a long time to
fetch a single record and on the right
we have the new tomorrow to normalize
data schema where there are only four
tables and just by normalizing data we
were able to improve cxp export speeds
by eight times so Finance was very happy
where they increase moving on to the
fourth one we decided to keep separate
bookkeeping for billing versus for the
event log and this means that and the
reason we decided to do that is that we
talk to our counterparts in sales and we
realized that the part that's most
likely to change in the future
is our billing model we may not always
bill on a per order basis we may choose
to introduce new pricing models or
subscription-based or SAS models and so
having separate records for billing
allows us to extend to incorporate those
in the future so here you see that you
may have events that don't map one two
one two transactions and that's and
transactions are stored an entirely
separate table or database as mentioned
this allows you to get stable tracking
of which events fit into each invoice
you can also this also allows for later
adjustments for example if you were
missing event you can still adjust for
it by adding a billing record into your
invoice and lastly it allows for future
extensions and our billing logic
so at the top we have the immutable you
down lock previously introduced and at
the bottom we have a separate record for
financial transactions and when we first
introduced the service financial
transactions are one-to-many for event
logs and this data is only to injured is
only used by our billing team or as the
top data has more users including
marketing sales customer support and
then we are on to the last data design
choice which is self-heal for every type
of ETL pipeline you can't guarantee
everything will be accurate from the
get-go but you can design for it to be
easily recoverable and to self kill so
self kill for us means programmatic
detection and adjustments for errors we
found that previous data principles data
design choices we made really helped
with programmatic detection because we
have immutable data we can track the
data lineage and we can figure out if
something goes wrong we can't just
append a new event and so does having
separate records for billing as
mentioned having separate records for
billing means you have an immutable
completely separate record so if billing
for whatever reason doesn't match to
your events you can always adjust for it
because you can compare them
side-by-side and add in a later
adjustment and lastly something we
discovered later is it's very important
to limit points of failure because it is
extremely expensive to build in new
adjustment pads so if there were fewer
points of failure you have the fewer
paths or ingestion point into adjusting
core data you need to support so a
couple examples of how we were able to
do this when an order was processed late
it was never reported for whatever
reason and it doesn't make it into its
private billing cycle we automatic
detect and added to the next billing
cycle
and we also automatically check our
billing records against the event
records and make adjustments if they
don't line for whatever reasons what
we've learned and these are like a
couple learning specific to financial
data we found staple ID and ordering to
be key so one thing that really helped
us out was we set the sequence we set a
sequence number and a unique order ID
extremely like at the entry point for
order ingestion and we carried those two
fields all the way downstream this means
that I've every step in the processing
pipeline we can always map event back to
the point of origin which is very
helpful for debugging and some quirks of
financial data we discovered you never
want to use floats if you see a rounding
error it's most likely because the flow
stuck in there somewhere
we also found that in for like financial
data there are a lot of dates and
getting clear definition for those dates
from the get-go is really important we
found that our external users tend to
use those days to map events into their
system so any change to those dates or
break something in their system and
lastly we discovered the data double
entry which is to have one record for
say when we pay a partner and separate
record for well well I guess two records
for every transaction really doesn't
matter it mattered more when you're
using paper trails and having the
balancing allows you to check one side
against the other so changing the data
schema was part of kind of a bigger
rebuild process where we actually we
used the the new financial data store to
kick off revamping the entire order
processing pipeline this was our old
processing pipeline where we had money
train that's what we call the financial
data store being responsible for almost
like seven different type of use cases
we found the database to be extremely
slow users were complaining it was not
performing as anticipated so we moved
all the data from the old data store
into the new data store and made the
OData store only responsible for
Commission logic and this was kind of a
fairly like involved migration so and
there were a couple things that we
learned from that which is when you do
this type of migration I won't get into
details you want to compare the foe data
set instead of just comparing new events
we had a script that did Apple to Apple
comparison for incoming orders but that
was not sufficient for capturing out
errors that came through as part of the
migration process a second thing to know
is that immutably has its benefits but
it does come with the downside of a hit
to your performance so you may very
likely need to add in pre-computation
for collapsing or event logs as after
introducing immutability and lastly this
is specific to the analytics use case
backfilling even a single event can be
painful because for analytics use you
don't anticipate data to be available
going forward only you anticipate data
to be always available which makes back
feel necessary so if you can avoid it
try to avoid it and just have the full
set of fields from a gecko
and lastly if things don't work out have
a rollback strategy so where do we
improve CSV was much faster our CX team
gets data lineage into how the order was
processed aggregation is simpler not
just for data scientists for users of
Excel but also for our jobs we didn't
need to write like very complicated jobs
to perform aggregation and lastly we got
doob immediately we're able to enable
programmatic detection and correction so
some future extensions plan
is to add additional dimensions we're
collecting new newer attributes and self
lights self derived attributes for users
so we'll likely append that to our
financial data for sales team their
experience experimenting with different
pricing models and that's something
we'll like likely need to support in the
future both experimentation part and
also the different pricing model part
and the last one is when we do hit a
performance bottleneck we haven't seen
that yet it might be the time to move to
a better storage engine than Postgres
and that is my top questions actually so
in one of the later slides I noticed
that you have this order closed date but
is there is there ever any data in which
you don't like you don't have some sort
of like I'm wondering if you have a some
kind of an event that comes in let's say
for the month of January but it comes in
you know several months later how do you
deal with let's say an aggregation query
you're trying to figure out what's
happening in January but you don't know
what the sort of upper bound on the
query is supposed to be that's why we
ask a user to use a different day we
have one day that's never changing and
that's a day we ingest an order into
your system so if we want a user to like
can say for a matter of fact that after
this point in time you would not see
data change we ask them to use that and
as for close date we use closed a to
represent when an order was actually
built to the partner and that's also not
something that's modifiable so say that
you fill and later order comes through
and it was not built until January that
closed they were always being generated
and the order would never be counted for
it towards previous billing cycle I
guess my answer would really be that
every record for day is kind of a source
of truth for when what the day presents
and depending on different use cases we
advise users who different use different
dates for
and we do have to support indexing on
all of the dates mention because like
our users do query on almost query and
filter on almost every one of them and
yeah that definitely adds a database
load for writes but so far it has not
became a bottleneck
[Music]